god damn am i carrying this again
everything I do yeah yeah finish our
rich boys will be selling let me ask you
guys this you're gonna buy a CD from a
comic are you more likely to buy a CD
from a comic with his shirt on how many
people want to buy is how many a CD
take it off you'll buy a CD how many
people you all better buy CDs
yes yes
[Applause]
there you are in this you did how about
ladies little miniskirt off and can I
tell you he said before the show this
evening in all earnestness D whatever
that word is Miss Merna sness he's boss
just said earnestness goes to key by the
way boss you look you look good you did
is it me or just voice of a body like a
pregnant Roach rich moss looked me in
the eyes and said it under under no
circumstances would he be taking his
shirt off
he said Sam don't even bother trying cuz
it's gonna be a waste of your time and
everybody's time because I'm not taking
my shirt off - about CDs yeah yeah heard
the cha-ching the applause from the
owner really really played that game
like a game of chess strategy when it
was I just ate a big [ __ ] meal that's
alright you look good by the way well
you know what I love about confident
boss now he's got two buttons unbuttoned
and his chest hanging I just let
everybody know I mean when his back was
turned who's putting it back on for a
second he went like this Joe himself is
6